four houses coming back for season five
I know but it's like the intimacy that
is supposedly the finale right and your
dragon how are you drag it out well let
me split up in two parts so I think like
nine episodes each okay could there ever
be a fullest house maybe I'm also
thinking about what happened so that it
may not be the end I think there's a lot
of energy I haven't spoke about this at
all I'm not going to really but there's
a lot of energy still with that show as
you said I mean there you don't look at
your daughter after the show she's how
was she is 11 or 12 just turned 12
there's too much there's too much and
there's too much happiness at that show
is brought forward a lot of people right
yeah so well you know it's not gonna go
down easily I'm not gonna like it
I know how would you feel that would
like be like comes back letting her down
right 35 years are you prepared for like
this final season season final scene
when it happened
fortunately it's not gonna happen like I
said but yeah you know it's become the
kid the girls I just sort of produce it
now I'm not you know I'm on someone but
it's become the girls show and I think a
lot of that ending a lot of the
storylines are gonna be around an event
around them yeah okay just I'm sorry I
think life has gotten so busy we've
forgotten to make time for each other I
miss you I miss you too I know Laurie
you guys have been supportive cuz you
guys support each other even though it's
like a tough time how do you deal with
the assets of that in the show I haven't
we haven't yet I haven't I haven't been
on the show yet so that it hasn't come
up and I'm gonna talk to some people
about it this week to see what's going
on and figure it out right figure it out
yeah um it's I've been I've said
everyone I was gonna wait a little
longer
all right can let me talk about it but
it's it's a difficult situation for
every one of them I know it would be you
know everyone everyone I'm sure it's
tough and I don't mean just our son
hates to spell yeah I know and cuz yeah
I know that's very difficult you didn't
you know you'll do a great job who do
you do a great job with everything so
I'm sure it will be handled with poise
and grace et speaking exclusively with
John Stamos at his first ever art
exhibit at the Malibu lumberyard have
you ever had your art hung in together
anywhere before
no no I think I was more nervous about
tonight than a lot of things really yeah
why because it's a personal I think so
yeah and I'm not you know I've I've
always you know well I'd love to art
when I was a kid I always did it but I
just I've been procrastinating you know
like painting a draw painting drawing
you know just and as my dear friend
Jamie Lee Curtis says if not now when I
was like that makes sense I get this out
I can't do it
so this means you're gonna be given us
more art I have about 15 more pieces
that are all part of this preset
idolatry and the teen idols in world and
I mean you know there's this kind of
thing doesn't exist anymore there's no
magazines anymore it's all online and I
mean when I wanted to see how popular I
was back then I'd have to go to you know
a mall or something we couldn't check to
see how many by now changed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]